you
well thanks for thanks for coming odd i
know it's going to take time at every
evening as you know always always a
trade-off but i appreciate you
appreciating being here for using using
python to solve problems so I
abbreviated abbreviated bio as I've been
I spent the majority of my career
working on data tools I think people
often call me a data scientist but
really I'm I've spent most of my time
making them tools for the data
scientists has been comparatively little
time actually doing data science
although I secretly secretly want to be
doing more modeling and modeling and
data science but find myself gravitating
toward toward the tool making I did
several years ago make an honest effort
to go back to grad school and get a PhD
in statistics but I dropped out in favor
of working on up working out the rules
so I guess as context for for this mood
for this new project I during the first
part of my career when I was eight you
are it is where I got interested in data
tool making in the first place I found
myself and in one finance basically
writing sequel and using Microsoft Excel
and looking for solutions for that and
only for building production code that
can be run every day
doing interactive research and just ad
hoc analytics so and this was kind of a
solution to both of those problems to be
able to consult production build
software effectively but also who work
out of the sequel and Excel workflow
that I was I found myself and get into
love so we all look Python and the world
is a lot different than it was seven or
eight seven or eight years ago when i
started out programming in Python it
used to be the end to have all these
arguments about you know can we trust
python and production is it a serious
programming language maybe we should be
doing java or c++ and thankfully we're
not having as many of those kinds of
arguments anymore in part because the
tooling and the software development
tools the data tools can become a lot
more mature and so big companies find it
a safer choice because there is a mature
ecosystem of tools there's also
community supportive developers those
resources for learning how to program in
python and generally but also teams of
data people that have front track
records now
using Python over a period of years that
have been successful so back in you know
2006-2007 there wasn't that track record
it was chicken in a problem where there
were no successful teams that had
multi-year stints of doing Python data
stuff people were just starting out to
do it and so if you're choosing to solve
those kinds of problem with Python it
may be seen a little bit little bit
weird at the time but now it's it's cute
as a safe choice and for lots of good
reasons the president is definitely
struggled to to move beyond the medium
data types of problems which fit so I
describe medium data is data that fits
on one machine I guess you could also
call data that fits on one machine small
data but I think a small data is data
that you don't have to be that careful
about the size so nowadays you can get
machines with 100 you know two terabytes
of ram you can get nodes on ec2 with two
terabytes of ram and so the definitely
you know the set the problems that now
our medium data are quite large which
whereas even having 10 or 20 gigabytes
of days to be used to feel like big data
because you need men machines to solve
it but if you do have a properly big
data using python is still problematic
and the way the data science is used
around the problem is by using another
system to sample or aggravate the data
and get it into the size where it can
fit fit on one which one machine so if
you have a problem or you need to
analyze you know the full fidelity data
set if you have many terabytes or
petabyte of data maybe the things that
you're doing with the data are not very
not very complicated I think in general
you know treble you see is larger the
date of the lesson is to create the
analysis largely just counting things
when dating it's really big but still it
would be nice to be able to use Python
in a full-featured full-featured way
regardless of the size size of the data
and some of the reasons for that and I
kind of generalized the world a little
bit into these two categories tools and
so there's there's been a chicken egg
chicken and egg problem in the Python
community that the glasses the class of
tools tend to fall into these these two
categories on one hand cited the
computing tools and people been doing
scientific computing in Python since the
mid-1990s and part of the reason that we
have nice things and went on is because
there were a lot of grad students were
procrastinating on their PhDs and wanted
to have alternative to alternative to
matlab and so they invested heavily in
creating and wrapping all wrapping them
all the legacy dynamic libraries
creating really good interfaces to
high-performance cooking tools linear
algebra
and all that stuff you started with it's
sci-fi in 1999-2000 that era numpy
itself is going to have its 10th
birthday early next year I believe under
the exact date but it's getting up
around ten years old but people have
been doing a multi-dimensional array
containing a Python for many years but
if you look at you know what people say
big data in Silicon Valley and it might
be the big data is different depending
on who you talk to you larger the
evening data that's pulling on the left
side but this of this page which is more
heterogeneous structured data that could
be written a CSV file or in some form of
application log file increasingly
increasingly it's JSON and in a sense
work this happened elsewhere like
outside the pipeline community has
encouraged this because application
developers who are Ruby programmers or
Python programmers are no just
programmers or they're in the Java
ecosystem they're all putting their
application data often through the same
pipe through the same pipe its landing
and some distributed storage in data
that's you know let's just store the raw
data in JSON the figured out we'll
figure it out later and so the tools
carburized to rise to the occasion in
the you know dude ecosystem with
MapReduce now it's important or more and
more spark you have really good tools or
analyzing such data with sequel code in
a general you know this is how how
things have have shaped out shook it out
and you know python great stuff over
here less messed up on the left side in
changing show so if you look at if you
look at and those pins was an effort to
to build an industry and with its
toolkit using the pythons scientific
computing stack and if you look at if
you look at canvas the library are the
reason that it's grown so large because
it had to find all of its own concerns
it had to build its own in-memory
analytics engine all of its own
relational algebra joints has to has its
own CSP reader has its own interface
with sequel databases it implements its
own data types
there's data types that occur in the
wild which are not found amongst numpy
as data types it has to handle its own
missing data because nobody doesn't have
a built-in notion of missing data it a
lot of the reason that people stick with
it is because of its its API and so that
the pandas cook you right it is true
that every time you execute the
statement with pandas it's immediately
executing the operation but you can also
look at the pianist copyright holistic
alee as a domain-specific language for
describing your data transformations
your analytics all your all of your day
of work and so in a sense a question
that I get from people a lot is Wes I
want to keep using pandas I just want it
to work with big data and it it's a
complicated that's a very complicated
problem in a sense the work I'm doing
now is is to address is to address that
need the meanwhile there's lots of
seagull engines and the sequel engines
often are created for some you know for
some problem domain whether you know
your facebook I mean you can have an
engineering team build your build your
app
database some of them are rich- vendor
some of the broken stores closed source
and these systems have generalized to
meet the needs of Industry Alex a lot of
ways I'm sure you're aware of and so you
know the big trend that I see and will
be the theme of this this talk is that
in big data in general one of the one of
the novel things with things like Amazon
s3 and HDFS news distributed file system
is that it's he couple the storage part
of the problem from from the other
systems that are part of the equation so
you can use MapReduce with HDFS but it
used to be when people said to do they
really meant HDFS and do produce whereas
now Emma whole smorgasbord of computing
tools which know how to read and write
data to HDFS they've also reading write
data to Amazon h3 to hbase other storage
engines in the they're all open source
so it used to be you would buy human by
a system that is vertically integrated
user interface is probably sequel it has
its own built-in compute engine its own
storage and so when you buy when you buy
amazon redshift you're paying for it as
a service but really you're buying into
a vertically integrated stack of you i
compute and storage but an open source
you know these things
so if you have your data you can put
your data wherever you want you bring
your own compute with that spark or app
reviews for a sequel engine it's up
hence the rise of super long to do but
that leaves the user interface being
area where there's been comparatively
little there's been apparently a little
invested and a major reason for this is
that the storage and compute is hard
enough and so you know in terms of like
a you know Maslow's hierarchy of needs
for for big data in a sense user
interface and the quality of the user
experience interacting with the data is
the part that comes at the tail end of
the equation after you fully addressed
the scalability and performance problems
of the compute storage systems and so if
you think about if you think about big
data architecture so how appropriate
that we're linkedin like you know have a
big data architecture which uses Kafka
which
linkedin but you know you see in more
and more systems like this where you
have a lot of real-time data that's
being ingested landed in raw form
usually in JSON or some other platform
at you write a detailed job to convert
the raw data to clean it to pull out the
stuff that you're interested store in a
more efficient format which is
increasingly something like like Apache
parkade calm nerves and press call
perform at then you consume that etl
data and some compute system besides but
you know galaxy Kalenjin here as as an
example but you think about these
architectures there's relatively little
Python happening in them and to choose
to choose Python in any stage of this
this architecture would come at the cost
of performance or usability and so
usually what you see is that python is
copying down in this area where a lot of
the work has already been done you
you're right you write a sequel created
you get the data back into a panic data
frame and then you do your bottling
analytics data visualization you know
ever so the cool thing about single on
the new systems that are being created
as the their ability to address their
they're getting better at doing but more
reflects data so he used to be if you
look at you know your big data
architecture they half of the work
that's happening in your
in your ETL jobs is taking data isn't
necessarily flat and normalizing it into
a set of tables that can fit into a flat
relational database structure and with
the addition of nested nested or complex
types of work to handle its sequel
systems is that you can analyze JSON
data directly in place without having to
having to go through that flattening you
know probably normalization stuff you
still have you know there's still some
work to do you have to you have to infer
schemas that's a pretty hard problem by
itself but assuming that you can write
down a schema for your data and your
sequel system knows how has that schema
support given your data you can bring
queries that are very expressive it can
analyze that data in place and so Google
bigquery is a my understanding is a SAS
efficacious of Google's Dremel system
which was published about in 2010 which
means that google was doing analytics
equal on JC my data back in two thousand
three or so so there's a long history
it's it's been shown to be a pretty good
way of working with working with this
kind of data so the project I'm building
I this which I started when i joined
join but era a year ago is a user
interface layer well it's a little more
than user interface and i'll explain but
really it's intended to be the user
interface layer for Python programmers
doing in history analytics that hides
away as much
complexity as possible the storage and
compute problems and enables you to do
your phone work with with big data
without having to lead Python or leading
Python as little as little as possible
so you know that solves you know I think
that I didn't really have experience
with big data systems starting a year
ago like I was really a small and medium
data kind of person and so I looked at
this and said well it's fortunate that
when you go from small medium data to
big data you have to learn a whole use
of tools you have to climb a bunch of
additional learning curves normal bunch
of new systems whereas what you're
actually doing with the data in a lot of
cases isn't that complies just happens
to be that python isn't very good
talking to those systems and integrating
with an integrated with them and so I
sat down with various teams around cut
area and said well how can we how can we
build a better synergy between I didn't
use the word synergy but using though
how can we connect iphone to Big Data
Systems in a cleaner more efficient way
to deliver the kind of experience that
you'd like to see you know in the next
you know within the next few years and
so for the purpose of this talk and
we'll talk about two areas of concrete
things that we're doing with the project
and the first is to move sequel
programming out of the sequel
programming language in
python and in a way that looks and feels
a lot like pandas and so the other the
other part of the problem which is
conveniently cut by cup I'd scream
screen divider is extending analytics
equal systems with a Python code you
know not just a noisy bulb and what a
sequel happens to be the target but
extending these big data complete
systems with Python code in a way that
doesn't trade away an unacceptable
amount of performance or ease delayed so
I'm going to talk about the I this dsl
which is the deliberately had this like
expression layer which the design goal
out the game was to look at the sequel
the sequel programming language and
let's to make sure that anyone can take
their gnarliest crazy as a sequel you
know 100 200 line queries and break it
apart into composable reusable Python
statements that so that that so that
anything you're doing a sequel can be
fully fully imported full importantly
Python so if you look on the website is
actually a new document which I wrote
last month call ibis for sequel
programmers the grant that goes through
every granular sequel relational concept
and that's how you can map those sequel
concepts on to the equivalent I this hi
this calls it's a part of her that I did
there they looked at not only real real
role you know customer
queries legs and like this crazy a 200
light to turn on query you see you know
what people are doing data there's also
benchmark sweets to evaluate the
completeness of sequel engines that you
can use things like TV CH and TP CBS if
your database junkies in the room that
you can use to really stress the your
ability to generate complex sequel it
did targeted Paula and the focused on
developing tools that will work well
with Paula for a couple of reasons that
I'll explain but the general sequel
generation tool chain insight I this is
very general purpose and so I'm looking
for vibrators which might be people in
the room to build support for other
analytics equal back up so high on the
list of wants and I this are a redshift
presto Verica postgres which is not
really at least equal but if you do if
you do some co stressing sub-branch ft
they kind of help each other because
you're all working on basically a
comment a common sequel dialect
and so the way that this in a way that
the project works if you write Python
code it hides as much as possible what
of what happens down in the compute
layer we are working on tools to extend
battling sequel systems with user /
compulsions that will be in the second
guitar now I'm going to go into a demo
will show you what the only what the dsl
looks like a little bit about I I need
to come up with like a three or five
minute demo for talks but the oh look at
the ibis for sequel programmers it's
broken down and so even like reading
stuff like exists you know sub queries
and things like that like all that stuff
isn't here shows the public I concur so
yes the intent is to be the intent is to
be very very pants like so while I can't
I can't promised to exactly pork the pan
this API to an expression language that
compiles to Big Data Systems the idea is
to get as close as possible or at least
to take every API and concept from
composable you know our org andis like
tools and make them available executing
on Donna on a different backends so you
know API and all
up there so let me try to record the
screen kids so I'm also operating a blog
which I haven't posted on I do since
mid-september they've been traveling but
is both a development kind of developer
blog as well as these cases and examples
of using the new project so I'm going to
use the sequel sequel light I'm is
interface so I have a data set
containing which you could download from
the from the blog it's linked to from
the block containing the crunchbase data
set slightly updated but that's because
they won't give me access to the latest
want like I don't know if I don't know
why maybe if you know anyone in
crunchbase you can tell them like West
wants the data once the data he's going
to write about it as I popularized
crunchbase I think it's a great day to
send and so if you look inside it it has
it has a set a set of tables and the
idea with the with the project is you
you grab let's look at the round table
so that's capable and I this feat is
like a pandas dataframe except the data
is not on your computer and so any time
you build you build an operation let's
say around old 5 that's just like the
equivalent in this operation whenever
you try to examine the expression you
create by this takes an expression
compiles it to whatever back and target
runs the query and returns the results
and its data frame so effectively what
you're doing also promoting execute
method which returns a data frame and so
any any operation you perform returns to
the appropriate pandas object so if you
have a table expression you get a table
if you say you look at Browns raised
amount USD dot some it shows you this is
the total amount that's represented in
the data set and these are all
expression objects that you can reuse so
here my call raising about human screwed
on some I get a double scalar expression
and so the fact that if you look inside
the object and you're developing there's
a little expression tree which shows all
of the operations that you performed on
the data so here's the you know column
from this table which has the schema
some operation which produces just a
single number and so you can take this
expression and say well really I want to
maybe group by rounds under quarter and
then maybe aggregating with that
expression it's called
so any aggregate expression you can put
here any grouping expressions you can
click here and when you look at this guy
you just get a total amount raised I'm
outraged by corner and so you see here
if you suppose you wanted to group I you
know quarter name you have to actually
transform the data set a little bit so
we can just do that right now here we go
I'm importer let's call strip on it is
it's a string and now let's do right to
actually i will try this over lmc okay
so so we see so we strip it do right
right to which go to the right two
characters so we can take this guy so
let's call this quarter
give the name quarter now group I
quarter and so now you get some Q 1 2 3
q for you could pass a list of grouping
expression it's just like in canvas you
can put a list of metrics here like
suppose I wanted to also get number of
rows so brown cow so there are some
moles in the data set so if you wanted
to do some cleaning you can do you can
continue composing an adding operations
so i can say fill an a if you all fill
an a after after doing the data waging
building a unknown
so
so get on to something slightly more
complex so I look side friends who work
it started to analytics and we're there
and so and this query were they compute
like the most successful investors based
on whether or not they had access so
like the number of investments that
they've made / a number of those
investments that led to either IQ or an
acquisition so you can go on and look at
this look at this example on on the blog
you see there's some there's some
bunging here where you define what is an
exit you do a count distinct on that you
look at you do have stink on the number
on the company permalink which is how
companies are identified and that's
after doing a join of investments on
companies then finally you have an
inline view you compute the acquisition
rate by investor so what's nice about
the about the iOS version of this is
that you take this you know Dustin
sequel career with a bunch of embedded
expressions and you can break it down
into a set of reusable reusable
expressions so here's just a walk you
through what this looks like so there's
some cleaning that you do on the
Investor names you fill an AIDS give it
the name the best
you compute your two metrics of interest
so the number if we need companies for
each investor their statuses so either
if your IPO requires easy isn't function
just like pandas do a boolean death else
so no loud once that are not I feel
require call count distinct on that
which is the enemy function then do your
joint the joints are all reusable and
then you group group aggregate and then
use the mutate function inspired by by
deep liar to add the acquisition rate
crawl up to the aggregated table so you
run that and you get 3 h investor and
acquisition grade and you continue going
and say well call that's fast too yeah
so then you can take you know forget
about all that other stuff you did now
say I want to filter down to all the
investors that made over 100 investments
sort by acquisition rating ascending
order and then you get your top 20 most
successful investors and so
Conway just leading leading the pack by
a significant margin so anyway sequel
future so we're featured completely
sequel that was the first major part of
the project so if you do use the library
and you find something you can't do
sequel please make a booking for it
that's that's my attitude toward it
alright so I did that already so there's
some interesting stuff going on apala
that we're you know I this is helping
steer development in Apollo and the main
thing that's happening there and some it
takes some time is how to extend a
distributed computing system with Python
and achieve good performance so if you
think about the problem schematically
you want to take Python code which is at
the UI layer and move that Python code
into the queue lair and have it run not
as is without you for some translation
or compilation step and there are a lot
of you know compilations will score tied
it on but they're limited if you have
libraries that you've built up over the
period of years which are written in
Python there's no chance i'm translating
them we're compiling them all of your
domain specific logic that you want to
run in a distributed environment key
like to be able to move back there
they're halfway to extend this
efficient way this is extremely hard
though which I'm sure many groom are
aware of this that extending any
distributed computing system usually
involves implementing user-defined
functionality so you know let's say you
know you're using presto and there it is
a way to extend presto with with your
own code when you have to write in a
Java there may be a way to write Python
functions or extend presto there's now
you can have a stand redshift with
python functions but they're extremely
limited and so the way so what I call
the extension with the language is not
the implementation language of a compute
system so I call that the external
language protocol so usually sometimes
you you can have you know an external
language borough hall which is embedded
in the system and so you've seen like
big data i don't linkedin like JRuby and
any of the j kind of implementations of
dynamic java implementation syntactic
languages got really popular because you
could rightly d s not a job if the
processes that executes the code live
outside of the host system usually
you're dealing with with a priest pretty
serious performance about leg and so if
you're writing Judy absent redshift good
you're basically making group interview
interprocess calls between the reg
ambassador process and an external
process and usually your skier we're
operating on a 102 time data model which
I'll talk a little more about the same
issue same issue is true of sparks or
using Python the spark can you write
anything that can't be expressed as the
dataframe API call you're dealing with
pretty significant pretty significant
performance overhead there's a lot of
things you can do through the app
interface the only need a simple data
transformations you can also express a
large class of statistical machine
learning models as aggregate functions
in in sequel type systems and so the
reason the reason that the UDF are are
slow and there may be other reasons but
typically it falls into these three
categories of problems so the first and
the biggest issue in practice is how the
data moves between the host system and
the external language so if your Python
it's how does you know so if you're
interested if your if your Impala your
press to know your postgres how do you
actually get the data that's flowing
around this distributed runs fine how
you get into Python so that's you know I
all serialization overhead there's also
the computation model and so with Python
it's generally accepted knowledge that
you don't want to operate on one value
of the tonight Python you want to
operate on one array of time and the
array should be as large as possible so
that you can effectively be
orchestrating very fast C or C++ code
with Python function calls though
there's also the question of how the
hell out into an external process and
indeed you know inter process
communication or remote remote procedure
calls introduce significant overhead
into any external external yet so just
looking at vectorization is one one
place where a lot of performance gives
you know here's a sequel statement with
a boolean condition selecting one value
for true true the true bridge x + y to
the false bridge if you look up let this
in Python I'll explain this diagram I
don't you read it but so the x axis is
the size of the array that is being size
of the array that's being operated on so
this right line right here is arrays
that have thousand ailments and 5,000
over here the green line is
the one line so that's the pure python
implementation of this some of the
boolean with would join condition and so
at the blue line so this miss vida y
right here here is 50 XP oh this is 100x
pedo 150 x and the blue line is a naive
implementation using numpy and extra
vector function calls with temporary
variables and everything so you know the
simplest thing you can do you solve
Ector operations and that you know when
you end up at around 50 large raise and
so if you avoid temporary raise if you
use Saipan to generate C code you get up
to you know the red line is the simplest
precise estimate change i can write and
then I you know use kind of cyclone
tricks to geek out another 50 x speed up
but these kinds of speedo is going from
scalar to to vector operations and
Python are very very common and so if
you're extending a big data system with
Python you'd better have a way to do
vector operations if you want your
private code to run fast and so what
we're we're doing to to deal with this
not only the scalar versus vector
operations but the larger general
problem how data moves efficiently
between between systems in particular
tabular data and analytical systems is
we are creating a shared memory
representation for tabular data that can
address Jay selling data and analytics
system so basically you can hand off
blob of data to a table or a data to buy
the process with this little conversion
or mob refer you know a little bit slow
conversion or modification is possible
our goal is to be able to get off the
data with no serializer deserialized
stuff so it's going to be as fast as you
would get out of a map coffee through a
shared memory shared memory region part
of the reason why we're focused on
Impala to do that first of all being you
know among sequel on new vengeance you
know one of the best of the bunch it's
also written in C++ which is nice as far
as they have performance being able to
do runtime cogeneration to accelerate
the management and moving around data
within the front side in particular when
you know that you have a Python good
yeah function call coming up so there's
a lot a lot that you can do there too to
achieve native performance you know if
that's her ass equals plus lvm framework
another reason is that if we improve and
we do at some point plan to improve the
llvm compilation tool chain and python
to address more normal x data so there
will be an interesting class for private
functions they can be compiled to LMAO
and those can be inserted directly
run time without need for any external
kind of any external data movement so
there's prior art on having standard
standard memory representation for at
least analects equal systems the Apaches
real project glitter that is another
safe want to do not just sequel and to
do but you can read from any systems
that officially initially designed their
Duke these cases it has a standard
columnar in-memory representation
tabular data that can address
substantial subset of JSON the same is
plan for Paula we're hoping that we can
create a format that can be used in
amongst all of these systems there's
already been a standard way at least an
open source of storing increasingly
standard way of storing compressed
calendar data that's the park a project
but the thing you have to realize about
you know how much you know you all
studied studying RK or calmer formats is
that there's an explicit trade-off in
systems like Parker tools like parquet
to maximize the throughput that you're
getting out of distributed storage so
here on HDFS or you're on s3 the ball
net and doing analytics on data that
could not be all memory resident are all
at all
cash is the slowest thing is going to be
the spinning disk hard drives it's more
and more flash and so the trade-offs
will change over time as increasingly
everything solid state disks everywhere
but with these serialization formats
they're designed for that trade-off
between I oh and cpu you're good so
compressed precedent code the data as
compact as possible while also being
able to blow it up to fully materialized
in every form as you stream through the
data to be male is another problem with
the suit collinar serialization formats
is that there is not a standard data
structure of the data into so if you if
you look at the park a java
implementation I actually have not so I
shouldn't I'm not an authority of the
matter but you know basically data is
being serialized into into native java
data structures if you're in C++ well
there's not even a simple a standard c++
implementation of parquet and so if you
were in Python and wanted to interact
with data parkade to have an efficient
data structure to exchange among systems
that know about compressed nest to call
nor data like parkade if you having a
bit of a bad time so this is a major
initiative that
right now to create a its standard data
structure for in-memory data coming out
of things like okay but can be friendly
friendly for Python it used to to move
data around amongst these these
analytical systems with minimal
serialization sterilization overhead
actually as a last week or so have a
cabinet and implementation underway that
will all be all the open-source China
we're trying to come up with a name for
the project so as soon as there is a
name there will be a github repo the
specification for the data structures
and reference implementations as soon as
i'm not that embarrassed to show my
messy c++ code to the world but
basically building enough to be able to
grade item of mine needs to be able to
interoperate with the systems that can
admit send and receive data in according
to that data structure so
highly technical but you know the grand
goal of writing more or Python and I
think some people think of me as being
like ideological about like it must be
Python or its craft but I don't really
feel that way like I think python is a
really great tool and the fact that you
have really accessible community of
developers and tools and a learning
curve does not too steep that building
software in fact that makes a lot of
sense to read your really broad audience
people who can now tackle data problems
that discussion about you know five ten
years ago so I like other programming
languages as well but I think that my
phone is a really great place to invest
and have it as a primary language for
data genes so anything that is blocking
using Python to solve certain classes of
problems strikes me as a real as real
issue and so you need to be able to
extend to extend these systems with
Python code and to do it without trading
away major performance so having these
common data structures is a key part of
that of solving that problem
so that's my mole being able to solve
big data you know without leaving the
ipad you know poker or you know whatever
type of development environment you
prefer you want to be able to bring the
software that you go and fight with you
without having to you know throw it out
completely so that means being able to
use existing pregnant in ecosystem tools
like tools like pandas scikit-learn of
pie and so forth you like to be able to
use them in big data environment that
having fully modified on fire workflow
obviously you have to write your
algorithms in a way is amenable to the
distributed computation model but all
the software has been created for
working at it partitions of data are
local in 1 nodes should be able to use
that software without participation in a
scalable big data environment so that's
all the that's all the slides I have but
I imagine there are some questions and
so I can answer questions for five or 10
minutes and we'll stick around for a
little while after the talking anyone
has you know more detailed questions
about the project and wants a good haul
would be happy to
can you repeat these so many questions
hi when is doing great bhai yes I i'm
not sure what the timeline will be but
it's it you know if that's personally
important to you like i would love some
help but i'm doing a lot of my stuff
with high-speed you see bike thing
Oh
yeah so I definitely I don't know what
time when feet I guess it's a function
of like how much help I app but I really
came to to get basically looks like but
basically a lot of the work in in the
project for granting sequel support is
mapping sequel built-in functions on to
the lots of the I this operation classes
and so the idea is like every every
sequel dialect is a little bit different
and so you know so maybe like you know
very hive has like approximate media to
use account and sketch you can map that
function name on to the CMS meeting in
class all the string functions things
like that so that's the main work it's
like it's a lot of legwork to wrap all
the gravel and Bill terms but adding hi
support wouldn't be too terribly much
work so it's wrapping built into adding
test coverage and then also added
support for you guys hi imagine these
lot of Heidi's 3tl and so like a big use
case for I this is ETO we're close and
so yes analytics big data
analytics also linked it to be able to
create like complex etl workflows that
are all with hive or higher and color
you have some sequel dive dialect that's
also you know do not have to orchestrate
like hand generated see verbal
statements a big win
yeah sort of I i will say i was going to
say something about that I i think it's
a it's an issue with my methodology and
i think that what's happening around
here is that like like garbage
collection overhead or like there's some
kind of like memory throughput issue and
like my benchmarking methodology that's
causing a problem so and maybe like
right around here you got like arrays it
like nicely fit like l2 cache and it's
like everything's fine by at around like
I'm not an expert there but I need to
publish the bench marking code and
somebody will
so so in that example you show for
compressing the large sequel to multiple
IVs command is important is all
intermediate steps past back to the
memory professionals like lazy battery
like a fancy spa yeah so if they're all
all the expressions are our information
yet so the question is in the the sequel
example with breaking down complex
sequel into multiple multiple statements
everything you created is an expression
so it doesn't it doesn't evaluate the
expression to tell you you actually go
to execute one of them so so everything
is deferred so it's the same like this
it's the same type model as as far or
other other dsl tank systems that you
build effectively computation graphs and
those get compile so i think that
building building spark support into my
this is also something that would be
really interesting so i think that the
is gsl maps nicely onto
spark dataframe operations and so so you
think it like I this is sitting like one
layer like one layer above API access to
the Sparkman competition law
okay um so was it possible that you
could have done this what cascadia
needed something at a sequel later that
other people also could leverage and not
just buy them at the general community
where you're a distributed layer above
the secret the jdbc would put in and
then you get access into
so the question is it possible to create
a layer that can be taken advantage of
by other other curry when there's other
environments I'm not quite sure i guess
i would need to I would need to see like
what that is with that that looks like
exactly I think so 11 major artifact
that will come out of this work is is
having a well-defined efficient external
way to extend systems with other code so
I'm focused on let's make this work with
Python but for it to work with our and
Julia or a arbitrary code that you write
and that's how to read and write the
same tabular tabular data format that's
so that's that's definitely something
that just isn't scope I also want to see
the same tabular data format make its
way it's a spark so we can get faster
you do spice Park so as far as like the
sequel kind of generation dsl like it's
very it's very coupled to be it's very
coupled to the python api so and
hypothetically you could if you wanted
to generate sequel you could like
generate Python code which generates a
sequel and that might be easier to
generate the sequel itself so
but I guess it's Turtles all the way
down sequels not going anywhere so
generating sequels you know pretty good
bad live you have you looked at the data
part I have looked at I've looked at
that's questions if I have I looked at
the dot o data frame library I have and
it's a it's very it's a very nice piece
of software it's about 150,000 lines or
just equals plus 11 there's a lot of
Python to it is it's definitely it's a
large code base it is definitely
tailored for machine learning so that's
a book like a good at
good in the bad way I don't know what
that is the link it's if you look at
it's like yes this is designed to be to
maximize usefulness for machine learning
so happy to see like better scalable you
know in memory not for data frame
libraries 93rd so i thought i'd
encourage them to like to look at your
operability with nanulak siebel systems
for four dollars a spring
what there being any practical elements
in terms of the size of the baby that
data and also what a mess make is the
performance the performance and
scalability is is limited by as limit if
I get to like a cute so it's in a sense
like as you know spark and Paula like
you know Big Dave heat systems get
faster and more scalable then the tools
like I this benefit benefit directly
from that in the UEF and the DMK's where
you're extending the system with with
Python there will be there will be
overhead I don't have an estimate of
like what the you know will slow down to
be over like hand-coded Android signals
plus right hand put a Java but the goal
will be to like bring them as close
together as possible I think that you
know in like benchmarks of know I food
versus you know hand-coded could it see
you know talking able to give
actor 23 so that would be like our
target I think so holla allegiance from
the perspective of the UI so I know that
sequel I like latency between like 100
milliseconds in a second tends to not be
like that much of a priority between
like one it's one second in 10 seconds
you know is is where like a lot of like
the optimization and latency like very
through credits taken into consider
consideration like systems like the
following you have you know gem that
takes place so like if you're operating
on upon your terabytes of data that like
the cogent time of generating llvm like
specializations for a query like it's
relatively trivial it's very much take
you know tens of seconds for like
minutes but yeah it depends on the data
that's on the what you're doing with it
the lion how the datastore whether it's
you know how two partitions what's how's
it stores a frozen for ks3 is the HDFS
you know how's your HDFS tunes like this
lot of factors so one question so what
machine might be a use case where is
that not a new space it is definitely I
think in general the extent that machine
learning models could be read reread
report were designed in a way that's
amenable to the distributive distributed
model yes systems like MATLAB Witcher in
database in database machine learning
spark ml the same same thing like
machine learning models regal for sort
of the Duke type architecture if I'm so
being able to access machine learning
models from a system like this you like
to be able to do your ETL feature
engineering analytics and the machine
learning within the same kind of
cohesive workflow without having to
first we have I haven't like step
outside your door workflow to
we need to do more advanced analytics
Thank